Rand Paul the Republican senator from
Kentucky
is being absolutely ridiculed for saying
look here's how Democrats are stealing
elections and when you go and you read
you see oh Democrats are stealing
elections by convincing voters to vote
for them and encouraging voters to go
out and vote or to vote absentee or to
determine how it is that they plan to
vote it's amazing that he even thought
this was a logical thing to put out
there so Rand Paul tweeted out
um two days ago a link to an article in
the American conservative okay the
article we're going to look at it's
called the Wisconsin purchase and a lot
of the article is about Mark Zuckerberg
Facebook and the center for technology
and civil Civic life's involvement in
Wisconsin okay and Rand Paul tweeted out
a quote from the article
adding how to steal an election so Rand
Paul says how to steal an election quote
seating an area heavy with potential
Democratic votes with as many absentee
ballots as possible
targeting and convincing potential
voters to compete complete them in a
legally valid way and then harvesting
and Counting the results this is called
elections this is called elections look
at what Rand Paul is saying the way that
Democrats have uh used trickery to win
is
figuring out where are there lots of
Democrats who might vote but they might
not going there convincing them to vote
and having them fill out absentee
ballots in a legally valid way in other
words voting running an election and it
really is worth looking at the actual
article
um that that is linked to and there is
stuff if you look at the article in some
total you will find a bunch of stuff
here about the influence of money
electioneering Mark Zuckerberg grants
using uh using entities to Shield uh
one's personal and like there's a whole
bunch of stuff in here that is not the
way I would like to see elections run
but it is legal and it is part of the
sort of status quo campaign Finance
structure that Republicans generally
speaking are absolutely fine with but
then the incredible part is you look at
the strata energy
and it's called running an election so
there's a heading called how the
Wisconsin five sought to implement the
Wisconsin safe voting plan and it says
the Wisconsin safe voting plan lists
four major strategic objectives first
encourage and increase absentee voting
by mail and early in person mainly
through providing assistance in
completing absentee ballots and
submitting them and installing ballot
dropboxes
there's nothing ominous there it's make
sure that people have places to drop off
ballots make sure people know how to
fill out their ballots completely legal
it's called voter engagement
second dramatically expand strategic
voter education and Outreach efforts
particularly to historically
disenfranchise residents
this is their Smoking Gun where where
this it the strategy literally is do
Outreach particularly to groups that
have been been historically
disenfranchised so that they know how to
vote where to vote what their options
are for voting how to get absentee
ballot wow how dark and ominous third
recruit election workers mainly from a
paid young activists who would replace
the usual older election day volunteers
get young people involved typically
these election day volunteers are older
that's a reality get young people
involved completely legal completely
good
um and a distant fourth in emphasis and
level of funding was fund covid-19
safety uh related covid-19 related
safety measures nothing remotely
concerning there just nothing remotely
conservative concerning there
um they also in the article
put in italics as if this is the Smoking
Gun and this is the part that Rand Paul
tweeted out but all of the resources
developed toward ballot curing drop
boxes vote Navigators partisan activists
infiltrating local election office Etc
were aimed at one ultimate end here's
their big Smoking Gun
as Rand Paul tweeted seeding an area
heavy with potential Democratic votes
with as many absentee ballots as
possible targeting and convincing
potential voters to complete them in a
legally valid way
than harvesting and Counting the results
this is what we call voting this is what
we call running an election and uh per
Rand Paul's explanation here is Stacy
Abrams who is also listed in this
article explaining how to quote steal
the election and by that I mean working
to win the hearts and minds of Voters so
that they vote for you here is Stacy
Abrams now you
restricting voting just in Georgia but
across the country so how are you going
to tackle this and keep up this fight in
2022
I'm excited to know that when the Senate
comes back into session in January the
U.S Senate is going to take up the
freedom to vote Act and the John Lewis
voting rights advancement act these are
two critical laws that will help protect
voting rights across the country because
it's not about partisanship this is
about patriotism my issue is that who
gets to vote it's that everyone who is
eligible is allowed to vote my job as a
candidate of course is to convince them
to vote for me but my job as an American
is to ensure that every eligible voter
has the right and the ability to cast
The Ballot so
um the the important takeaway here is
that for the Republican Party
this hasn't been the strategy for a
decade they are presenting as some kind
of concerning or disturbing strategy
making sure people have the wherewithal
and resources to vote encouraging them
to do so and targeting areas where
there's lots of potential voters for
your side that's called running an
election Republicans haven't done that
for at least a decade they essentially
gave up trying to convince voters on
policy in 2012 with Mitt Romney you
still had it a little bit when Mitt
Romney ran against Barack Obama
they still sort of were running on
policy although the policy was
increasingly vague and amorphous in 2016
it was completely abandoned policy was
completely abandoned Trump still said
things that sounded like policy but it
was not actually policy the 2018 midterm
then Republicans just straight up
abandoned policy in 2020 running on
policy was a distant memory and there's
no indication that in 2022 Republicans
are going to run on policy they're going
to run on trying to make it difficult to
vote and this is what they've been doing
make it difficult to vote particularly
for people that are not likely to vote
for you and run on cultural issues
critical race Theory
Etc you guys know the the roster so we
have actually seen
Democrats try to run on a platform of
policy and voter enfranchisement I'm not
saying it's a platform I love in all
ways I've had no shortage of critiques
and criticisms of the democratic
platform but it's been let's try to get
people to want to vote
and let's use policy rather than
cultural issues to do that and
Republicans running on cultural issues
running on fear if you don't vote for us
brown people are going to invade from
the southern border uh we're gonna take
away what was it Trump said they would
you they would give you toilets that you
have to flush 10 to 15 times and take
away indoor Heating and Cooling and all
these different things uh we'll protect
we'll protect the suburbs right
extremely racially coded language will
protect you from people taking your jobs
and you know raping and all these
different things so now when you
actually just run normal elections it
ends up being presented as this is how
they are trying to steal the election
this is called running an election this
is called politics and just another
completely humiliating public statement
by Senator Rand Paul we'll have it we'll
have that tweet of his and more coverage
of this on our Instagram which you can
find at davidpackman show you can also
follow me me on Instagram david.pakman
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee for sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies I've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over twenty thousand five
star reviews and best of all if you
don't love it you'll get 100 of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try four sigmatic is
giving my audience up to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic.com com slash Pacman the link
is right underneath this video